world leaders and thousands of
international decision makers have
gathered to discuss finance and business
at the International Economic Forum
earlier there the Russian president
warned of possible global threats adding
that the United States withdrawal from a
missile defense agreement is a step
towards destabilization our
correspondent Ilya Petrenko is out of
the forum to talk to him now
hi there when after President Putin have
to say hi again Colin well while right
now the wealthiest Russian businessman
and some of the wealthiest movers and
shakers in international business are
getting together here at the location of
the venue somewhere else at a lot of our
Putin's st. Petersburg residents he was
welcoming officials and also the heads
of the most important international news
agencies and what you just mentioned was
actually said during a meeting with them
and the Russian President had quite a
few very critical things to say about
America erasing the signatures on some
of the landmark treaties that have to do
with the control of the use of missiles
missile defense and so on here's what
mr. Putin said in particular it seems
like the global threat issues being
ignored that can't help but raise
concerns our American partners have
withdrawal from the anti-ballistic
missile treaty so what ladies and
gentlemen I would like to ask you did
anyone of you protests or takes to the
streets with placards no silence like it
was okay but this was the first step for
a fundamental destabilizing of the whole
construction of international relations
in terms of global security
you see every once in a while the
Russian leader reminds journalists and
the rest of the world as a result of the
collapsing important international
treaties that are being taken down by
the donald trump administration and one
of them is the intermediate nuclear
force intermediate-range sorry nuclear
forces treaty we remember how the
American president once said that Russia
wasn't playing by the rules so that's
why Washington decided to withdraw even
though Russia was saying that it's not
violating anything well right now mr.
Putin is saying that the government in
America is realizing that accountability
will be on the way and that's why
according to the Russian leader the
Americans are now trying to find
pretexts by blaming Russia for
everything that has to do with it
Vladimir Putin believes he's absolutely
certain that a transparent discussion is
needed for a possible revival of the
treaty or for possible new treaties that
could replace it he believes that these
discussions should involve professionals
from all over the world and in fact he
went on to say that he does have hope
that these kind of things could happen
guess why because he's in touch with
Donald Trump that's the latest
conversation with President Trump
instills a certain optimism in me Donald
told me he's also concerned he
understands the expense the United
States is the rest of the world put into
weapons of course today the most
significant thing is negotiations
between countries with the largest
nuclear potential but I think it is
necessary to involve all nuclear
countries official and unofficial this
may be the one light at the end of the
tunnel among other things we heard from
the Russian leader was a rather strong
statement that he was sick and tired
that the u.s. is using Venezuela as its
own backyard and also he talked about
the
change in leadership in the UK according
to Vladimir Putin Russia and the UK need
to turn the page and that page was
something that had to do with spiced
scandals and murder attempts and so on
so he believes the story should continue
with a new blank sheet okay so still
plenty to come between now in the end of
that forum on Saturday for now though
Elia Petrenko in San Petersburg thanks
for that right well let's pick up on
those comments from President Putin a
few hours ago we can talk to you Iranian
office who's a geopolitical analyst and
consultant welcome back to our tea the
Russian president called the u.s. one of
the major destabilizing threats in
global politics is Putin's assessment a
bit harsh they're singling out
Washington well I think if we look into
the past decades he is totally right
with that comment but in the past two
years when Trump was in office I
wouldn't see the picture as dark as
President Putin has painted it because
President Trump has prepared the
framework for the solution for some of
the most urgent conflicts that were
going on that were started on behalf of
Obama like in Syria
he has retreated his support for the
ISIL amidst rebel forces and this way
prepared the possibility to solve the
Conor but regarding this treaty's yes
the United States plays a very dangerous
roles role in ending for example the INF
treaty there was some pessimism as well
on treaties regarding the the START
treaty mr. Putin said that Russia won't
prolong the idea of that if there's no
interest how dangerous could that become
if a new treaty isn't established
yeah the New START treaty that was
closed in 2010 will end in 2021 and of
course the negotiations should start now
to make sure that it can be prolong
gaited but the basic problem that
both President Putin and President Trump
see is that China has never been
included in those treaties and so they
do not really mirror the present picture
that we see in the geopolitical arena in
the world China is an important player
China also has between 1,000 and 1,200
INF weapons installed in China so China
needs to get on board and that's why I
asked myself whether both President
Trump and President Putin have a
strategy to end those duties and to open
new negotiation rounds where pressure is
being good on China to be integrated
they have no interest in it but in the
interest of world peace China has to be
part of the game how difficult is it to
get those partners on the same page
though they're not just military
adversaries they're economic adversary's
as well now well I think this is the
biggest challenge that we are facing at
the moment in this decade in the
following let's say 2 or 3 decades that
we find a new security architecture
where not only United States Europe and
Russia is somehow integrated but also
China and President Putin has made it
clear already 10 or even 15 years ago
that he is seeking a partnership a
security partnership between Russia and
the West
and this has been utterly rejected for a
long time and now it's really time for
the northern hemisphere to sit down talk
and see whether they can find some
common ground and stability for the
whole northern hemisphere which of
course also includes Russia as a
neighbor of Europe and also China has a
very important driver of the Eurasian
integration process Venezuela came up
earlier as well in that press panel that
President Putin attended Russia says the
United States is using Venezuela as its
own backyard how do you think the US
would react to that
well I think it's an assessment which is
clear to everybody since 1823 the Monroe
Doctrine made it clear that Europeans
should not interfere in the Sierra
influence of the US and vice versa but
nowadays of course this doctrine is
being questions with we see that
Venezuela enters in a much stronger
partnership now also with geopolitical
players like Russia China but also
Turkey and Iran and so I think we will
see different ways of handling the
Venezuelan crisis not just like it was
2011 in Libya or 2011 also in Syria
where the West and the NATO could just
push its own agenda without any severe
resistance on behalf of Russia and China
so in Venezuela there needs to be a
negotiation solution and Russia and
China will play a role in that in the
future back to the forum in San
Petersburg then it's it's a massive
event there are thousands of delegates
there powerful people influential people
in governments and in business and
finance and although it's not a summit
it's not coming up with policy there are
some very important minds at that forum
how useful is it in order to try and
bridge that problem between geopolitics
and stuttering economies around the
world well it's a very important meeting
I assume it can be really already
compared to the weight the political
weight of the world dynamic forum
intervals and it just shows that the
multipolar structures are already really
becoming reality in the world and of
course a geopolitical aspects
always have to do with economy and
politics and military at the same time
so these are fora that play a very
important role to prepare also political
processes that then maybe negotiated
between nation-states afterwards so it's
like think tanks it's like brainstorming
platforms that have a great
Wade in international politics and we're
across what sir coming out of there okay
in Karlsruhe in Germany Reina offers
thanks for joining us
many renowned experts across various
fields are gathered in San Petersburg
for the next few days one is Eugene
Kaspersky founder of the Russian cyber
security company Kaspersky Lab he spoke
exclusively to us a little earlier
well actually where then they speak
about our so-called Russian hackers the
only time I say that we have our
benefits from the all this media
pressure because we live in Russia and
we are first to see Russian cars so our
technologies and products they protect
from Russian hackers much better than
our competitors everyone is aware about
the infrastructure about the side vector
and targeted attacks many of them they
speak the cybersecurity language was a
vulnerabilities zero-day attacks and
cetera but at the same time we're still
lot of work to do because the mostly
people think about the computer security
or smartphone security but it's not the
end of the story because they achieve
the all the kind of devices around us
unfortunately many agenda vulnerable
what about transportation security the
healthcare security because
unfortunately is all that is vulnerable
based on cyber in vulnerable and
unfortunately the cyber criminals the
bad guys from time to time they're able
to hack even the critical things so we
still have a lot of work to do on the
awareness now we're company which
provides cyber security for any kind of
businesses from individuals from their
individual devices to the critical for
structure and of course it's the next
logical step to assist governments
because there are many governments all
of them they recognize the cyber
security as one of the top top top
shoes so they pay a lot of attention to
this so we are able and we want to
assist governments with our knowledge
experience technology that was like a
company strategy to be a global company
to have our representatives the partners
and offices everywhere around the world
by in Africa it was one of the regions
which we paid attention also many others
but recently African some of African
countries leaders they started to pay
more attention to cybersecurity so we
are invited to the government level
conferences events so that was in Rwanda
and that was very promising
you